IT'S TIME TO PLAY 'BOUT TO DROP
THE HOTTEST MIXTAPE.
'BOUT TO DROP THE HOTTEST
MIXTAPE.
A PHOTO OF THE POPE SURFACED
THIS WEEK THAT MADE THE INTERNET
COLLECTIVELY SHOUT, "OH SNAP, IT
LOOKS LIKE HE'S ABOUT TO DROP
THE HOTTEST MIXTAPE OF 2015!"
HERE IT IS.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: YA.
HE'S LAYING DOWN THAT OL 'DIRTY
TESTAMENT.
THIS INSPIRED THE HASHTAG
#POPEBARS, WHERE PEOPLE COMPOSED
RAP LYRICS FOR THE NOTORIOUS
P.O.P.E. LIKE THIS ONE FROM
@CHEF LU BU:
"MY PSALMS ARE SWEATY, PAGES
WET, ARMS ARE READY, THE SPIRIT
IN MY BODY ALREADY, LORD'S
SPAGHETTI."
SHE CROSSED HERSELF.
TAKING YOU BACK TO HIGH SCHOOL.
BUT THE POPE'S NOT THE ONLY ONE
BRINGING THAT HOT FIRE.
COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU
A PHOTO THAT LOOKS LIKE A
MIXTAPE THAT'S ABOUT TO DROP,
AND FOR 250 POINTS, I WANT YOU
TO TELL ME MORE ABOUT IT.
HOW ABOUT THESE PANDAS WITH
ATTITUDE.
COLTON.
IS ALBUM HAS A GREAT TRACK. IT'S
CALLED
BREAM.
BAMBOO RULES EVERYTHING AROUND
ME.
>> Chris: WHAT ABOUT THESE SLIM
SHADIES.
> WHICH ARTIST IS
FEATURED ON THEIR LATEST TRACK,
TIFFANY?
>> THE BLACK DUDE THAT SELLS
THEM WEED.
>> Chris: POINTS.
TONE BELL.
>> THESE ARE THE YING YANG
WINKELVOSS TWINS.
>> Chris: POINTS, POINTS.
COLTON.
>> FEATURED ON THIS TRACK IS
RACHEL DOLEZAL, THAT WHITE CHICK
WHO SAYS SHE'S BLACK.
SHE SHOWS UP AND DROPS SOME
BARS.
>> Chris: WITH HER TRACK "SORRY
NOT SORRY."
>> YA.
Chris: NEXT UP PRESIDENT
OBAMA AND THE POPE HERE.
WHAT IS THIS RAP DUO, TONE.
>> THEM PUSSY CRUSHERS.
[LAUGHING]
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> Chris: POINTS.
TIFFANY.
>> I CALL THEM SALT AND PEPPER.
STRAIGHT UP.
SALT AND PEPPER HERE.
>> Chris: PUSH IT REAL GOOD.
COLTON.
>> OKAY THAT'S [BEEP] BITCHES
AND HIS HOMIE GET MONEY.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> YOU CAN FIGURE OUT WHICH ONE
IS WHICH.
>> Chris: NEXT UP THESE DIRTY
BIRDS.
WHAT IS THE NAME OF THE SONG ON
THIS MIXED TAPE, TIFFANY.
>> BITCH BETTER HAVE MY MUFFIN.
Chris: COLTON.
>> YA, YA THIS IS A CLASSIC
TRACK.
POOP, THERE IT IS.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: FINALLY, NASTY ASS JEB
BUSH IN HERE.
WHAT IS JEBB'S HYPE MAN SAYING?
I THINK GIVE IT UP FOR THIS DUDE
THAT LOOKS LIKE A DAMN RABBIT.
>> Chris POINTS.
COLTON.
>> WHAT UP PARTY PEOPLE JEBB
ABOUT TO COME OUT AS SOON AS
HE'S
DONE WITH HIS NAP.
HE WILL HAVE A QUICK TEA AND BE
OUT HERE FOR YOU.
>> Chris: POINTS.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: THE AIR HORN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: I LOVE THE MOUTH
GENERATED AIR HORN.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE THINGS.